Film Courage: When you’re presented with
a script, how can you tell good writing versus
bad writing?
Let’s say there’s writing with a few more
iterations which might be excellent and then
there are things where you know instinctively
this just isn’t going to work.
Rhys Thomas (Director of COMRADE DETECTIVE):
Good question…A comedy (as well) is a very
specific thing because there are writers that
are really good at jokes and they are just
really funny people but maybe sometimes just
don’t understand story.
So the structure…you might read something
on the surface that has really good beats
but as a whole it just doesn’t glue together
so the thing that I tend to look for first
in any script is a sense of story.
Does this person sort of know the story that
they are telling and did they understand the
structure of things and again it’s a sort
of subtle thing that you come to see.
And obviously is it a story that I like.
It’s like anything.
There are films and scripts and what have
you that are not for everybody.
So I may not enjoy a script but not because
it’s not good.
Maybe I’m not the person for it.
But a story is a thing that I think most writers
if they can get a good handle on studying
that and understanding character and motivation
and what have you that that’s the sort of
foundation.
The joke writing and stuff I think if you
can do that as well then you’re on a good
track.
But it’s really funny.
It’s quite rare to see people who can kind
of straddle both things.